[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى متابع هذه الصور
المباشره من الخرطوم في ظل هدوء حذرا يسود
العاصمه بعد الاعلان عن هدنه جديده بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع تمتد لثنتين
وسبعين ساعه
هذه الصور تريدنا من اليونان تحديدا من
مدينه كلماتا حيث اوقفت السلطات اليونانيه
عمليات البحث عن نجينا ومفقودين في حادث
غرق قارب في مياه المتوسط وما زال اكثر من
500 شخص في عداد المفقودين
وهذه صور من سواحل غزه عقب اعلان نتنياهو
ان اسرائيل ستمضي في تطوير حقل غزه مارين
للغاز بتنسيق امنيا مع مصر والسلطه
الفلسطينيه سنناقش هذه القضيه في جولتنا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
قرار اسرائيلي يسرع وتيره الاستيطان رغم
تلاحق التحذيرات الغربيه حكومه نتنياهو
تقر تعديلا قانونيا يخول وزير الماليه
اليمني المتطرف منفردا صلاحيه التصديق على
البناء الاستيطاني وتدرج على اجندتها خططا
لبناء نحو خمسه الاف وحده استيطانيه
واشنطن تبلغ تل ابيب بتاجير منتدى النقب
بسبب المخطط الاستيطاني الجديد
[موسيقى]
على وقع هدوء حذر في العاصمه السودانيه
بعد دخول هدنه جديده حيز التنفيذ نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده يطالب بوضع اليات تضمن
نجاح الهدى ويؤكد ان البرهان وحميتي
سيجتمعان لبحث وقف القتال والعمليه
السياسيه والاليه الثلاثيه تدعو الطرفين
للالتزام بحمايه المدنيين وضمان وصول
المساعدات وفقا لاعلان جده
معارك داري على طول الجبهات في اوكرانيا
في ثلاثه قطاعات بيزافولوجيا وكياف تتهم
القوات الروسيه بشن نحو 100 غاره وهجوم
صاروخيه على مناطق سكنيه
وتقارير استخباريه تؤكد تكبد طرفي القتال
خسائر كبيره في التصعيد الاخير
في اول زياره من نوعها منذ خمس سنوات
بلنكن يبحث في بيجين قضايا تايوان والتوتر
العسكري في شرق اسيا والتنافس الاقتصادي
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد اهميه استمرار
التواصل للحد من مخاطر سوء الفهم
والحسابات الخاطئه ووزير الخارجيه الصيني
يؤكد ان العلاقات مع واشنطن في ادنى
مستوياتها منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا ايقاف السلطات اليونانيه
عمليات البحث عن ناجين ومفقودين في حادث
غرق قارب كان يقل اكثر من 700 من طالبي
اللجوء امام سواحل البلاد الحادث الذي
يوصف بالثاني اسوء حادث غرق تشهده منطقه
البحر المتوسط زاد من الاتهامات الحقوقيه
الموجهه للدول الاوروبيه بشان مسؤوليتها
عن هذه الكوارث سواء بسبب التقاعس او فرد
قيود على عمليات الانقاذ او تصدير الازمه
الى دول الجنوب لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
كيف ستؤثر هذه الكارثه على سياسات
الاوروبيه المتعلقه بطالبي اللجوء عبر
المتوسط 30% قالوا انها ستغير بشكل جذري
في التعامل مع القضيه 20% قالوا انها
ستدفع نحو زياده التوجه الى المعالجه
الامنيه
بالتعاون مع دول جنوب المتوسط التي تشكل
نقاط انطلاق لقوارب الهجره بينما 50%
رجحوا استمرار السياسات الحاليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
هذه القصه ستبقى حاضره معنا خلال جولتنا
سنتعرف على شهادات الدقائق الاخيره ما قبل
الفاجعه واتهامات اقارب الضحايا لخفر
السواحل اليوناني
[موسيقى]
صدقت الحكومه الاسرائيليه على قرار ينص
على اختصار مراحل اجراءات البناء
الاستيطاني ومنح وزير الماليه
صلاحيه التصديق على قرارات البناء
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه من دون
الحاجه لموافقه وزير الدفاع بالتزامن
ادرجت الحكومه خطط الموافقه على نحو 500
وحده سكنيه في مناطق مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه على جدول اعمال المجلس الاعلى
للتخطيط الاسرائيلي
في قرار جديد الغت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
مراحل عده في اجراءات التصديق على البناء
الاستيطاني
لا يعني ذلك اي الغاء للمخططات
الاستيطانيه وانما تسهيل الاجراءات
وتسريعها واحاله اقرار البناء في
المستوطنات للوزير المتطرف المستوطن
الذي سارع الى الاحتفاء بالقرار
يستمر لازدهار العمراني في يهودا والسامره
وجميع انحاء بلادنا كما وعدنا نتقدم اليوم
في بناء الاف الوحدات الجديده في يهودا
والسامره
يسعى نتنياهو الى تسجيل نقاط لدى الائتلاف
الحكومي من اليمين المتطرف والمستوطنين
والوزير سموتريتش هذه الخطوه تدل على ضعف
نتنياهو داخل حزب الليكود وتيار اليمين
الرسمي مقابل اليمين المتطرف
ضمن لاجزاء واسعه من الضفه الغربيه الى
اسرائيل هكذا اعتبر الجانب الفلسطيني
القرار الحكومي الاسرائيلي مؤكدا انه
ستترتب عليه خطوات ستتخذها السلطه
الفلسطينيه بالنسبه لنا هو اعلان عن ضم
حقيقي للضفه الغربيه المحتله بما فيها
القدس الشرقيه ومحاوله لفرض القانون
الاسرائيلي عليها وبالتالي اغلاق الباب
نهائيا امام ايت فرصه لتطبيق مبدا حل
الدولتين
ذلك مع عزم الحكومه الاسرائيليه التصديق
على بناء الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومع زياره لمساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط يتوقع ان تعبر خلالها عن ادانه
اداارتها لهذه الاجراءات وعليه فان توقيت
القرار يؤكد عزم اسرائيل المضي في سياسه
تغيير الامر الواقع دون التفات الى ادانات
لا تغير شيئا على ارض الواقع
خطوه جديده تقطعها اسرائيل لتعزيز
الاستيطان وهذه المره تتجاوز حتى المسار
غير الشرعي الذي اتبعته الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه لاقرار البناء
الاستيطاني وهي تمعن بذلك في تجاوز قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه وتقوض اي امكانيه لاقامه
دوله فلسطينيه
في حدود عام 67
الجزيره من امام مستوطنه جبل ابو غنيم
القدس المحتله
وقبل قليل قالت يدعوت احرنوت الاسرائيليه
ان واشنطن ابلغت اسرائيل بان منتدى النقب
المقرر بعد نحو اسبوعين سيؤجل بسبب
الموافقه على خطط بناء نحو 500 وحده
استطاضيه
ينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من الناصره
جاكي خوري الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومعنى من نيوجيرسي
مبعوث الرئيس السابق بالكلانتن الى
مفاوضات السلام بالشرق الاوسط مرحبا بكما
سيد جاكي خوري السلطه الفلسطينيه اعتبرت
هذا القرار الاسرائيلي بانه تمهيد لضم
الضفه هل هذه المخاوف في محلها باعتقادك
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين اعتقد ان
مخاوفه الغربيه لم تبدا هذه الليله ولم
تبدا بهذا القرار اعتقد ان هذا المخطط
موجود منذ يعني فتره ويتم التعامل معه
بالحيل لاخر ويبرز على يعني الساحه وعلى
العناوين بفعل بعض القرارات التي تتخذ من
قبل الحكومه ولكن انا اذكرك واذكر
المشاهدين انه ايضا قبل عده اشهر عندما
تابعنا عمليه يعني الازمه التي كانت في
حينه في ظل تصاعد العمليات فيها طرفه
الغربيه وكذلك المخططات التي تحدثت عن
بناء الوحدات الاستيطانيه الجديده في حينه
ذهبوا ايضا الى منطقه العقبه وكذلك الى
شرم الشيخ في اجتماعات وفي حينه ايضا
اعلنت الحكومه الايطاليه انها بصدد
المصادقه على وحدات استيطانيه جديده وانه
لن يتم عمليه من هذا البند مجددا هذا هذا
اليوم عمليا ما اتخذ هو ليس قرار بناء
وانما قررت تسريع البناء وهي قرارات تمهل
عمليا للضم بشكل عملي ولكن هي جزء من حزمه
قرارات لم تبدا هذه الليله كما ذكرت ولكن
هي مخططات موجوده من حين لاخر يعود
نتنياهو وايضا بيضات وبعزم
ومن اقطار اليمين المتطرف لتفعلها على
الارض وبشكل يعني عملي ولكن يبقى سؤال
كبير الى اي مدى المجتمع الدولي وتحديداه
المتحده ستقف بالمرصاد لهكذا
نحن نتحدث عن حزمه قرارات جرى اتخاذها
اخرها هو هذا القرار الذي اعلن اليوم
والذي من شانه ان يسرع ويسهل الاستيطان في
الضفه بما قد يمهد لضمها كما تقول السلطه
الفلسطينيه كيف باعتقادك ستتعامل
السلطات الامريكيه مع ذلك
ان هذه لحظه حقيقه لبناء
فمن جانب هو هناك ضغوط عليه من العناصر
اليمين
وذلك للتسريع
بناء المستوطنات وكما نعرف ان بعض
اعضاء الوزير الوزاره لا يفضلون لا هناك
اي شيء اسمه فلسطين
واعتقد ان الدول العالم وخاصه ولايه
المتحده بدات تاخذ تعارض حصول ذلك فهناك
تصريحات
لقتل الولايات المتحده كانت وبصراحه
معاديه لفكره هذه المستوطنات طبعا لا نعرف
ما يحصل وراء الكواليس ولكن يبدو ان الامر
ليس مجرد كلام اذا حاليا هو هناك اعلان
وليس هناك حرب حقيقتان بدء بناء او تسريع
في البناء
واعتقد الرئيس الوزراء لديه مشاكل كثيره
محليه
بوجود كل هذه التظاهرات الاسبوعيه الكبيره
واذا قاموا ذلك اضافه مشاكله المحليه
فيعني انه يسعى نحو المشاكل طيب ولكن يعني
انت تتحدث عن ان الولايات المتحده بدات
تعارض عبر تصريحات وحقيقه الامر ان هذه
الاداره الامريكيه
تصرح منذ ان وصلت الى الحكم ولكنها كما
يقول الفلسطينيون لا تنفذ اي شيء على
الارض
وربما هذا ما جرانه الى الوصول الى هذه
النقطه
اول ما لا نعرفه وليم الدي اسباب تدعوني
انه هذا يحصل وهو انما قيل وما هي ما هي
الكلام الذي خلف الكواليس وهناك فرق
بينهما صحيح يبدو حاليا الامر مجلد كلام
من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه لكن الرئيس
بايدن هو رجل كان في خضم القضايا الشرق
الاوسط بوصل رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وكنائب رئيس بعد ذلك
للرئيس اوباما حيث كان يحمل ملف الشؤون
الدوليه وايضا هو يعي جيدا ما تكون تبعات
ما اعلن
واذا فعلا بدات هذه
هذه
المستوطنات ستؤثر على مستقبل دوله
فلسطينيه فلا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده
استقبل ذلك اما التبعات السماء
بالفعل بدات بدات تسريع وتيره الاستيطان
لا يعتقد السيد قدسين ان الولايات المتحده
ستقبل بذلك بالنظر الى التجربه باعتقادك
كيف يمكن ان تتبلور هذه الامور وما خيارات
السلطه الفلسطينيه حاليا امام ما يحصل
يعني اعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
ايضا من سبقها لو ارادوا التوصل فعلا الى
حل عملي في كل ما يرتبط بهذا الصراع
ومساله الاستيطان والحدود لتخذت القارات
منذ زمن وبالتالي لاحد يعول على اي تحرك
امريكي حقيقي في هذا الموضوع لربما قد
يكون بعض التحفظ لربما هناك بعض الخطوات
العمليه التي تعني بشكل يعني مؤقت عدم
تفعيل هذه القرارات ولكن من يتابع عمليا
المشهد عن قربه هنالك عمليه بناء مستمره
في الضفه الغربيه ولكن يجب ان ننتبه الى
جزئيه مهمه يعني في حكومه اسرائيل يعرفون
ان لا نتحدث الان عن عشرات الالاف
الاسرائيليين من الاسرائيليين الذين
ينتظرون يعني الحضور الى ضفه الغربيه
والاستيطان فيها ولكن كل ما يحدث الان هي
عمليه تمهيد لاي زياده تكون خلال الفتره
القريبه وايضا خلال السنوات القريبه
الكبار ان هذه قرارات ستفعل الان وايضا في
المستقبل اعتقد ان هذه الخطوات التي اتخذت
اليوم هي جزء من مجموعه قارات وحسمه قارات
كما ذكرت لاي عمليه لاي تعميق للاستطاف في
الطاقه الغربيه ولكن هذا لا يعني البناء
بشكل فوري وانما هي عمليه تسريع لوتيره
بناء عندما
تحذر من هذه الاجراءات تقول انها ستقاطع
اجتماع اللجنه الاقتصاديه العليا مع
اسرائيل ولكن ما خياراتها الان للتصدي
لهذا المشروع
يعني مقاطعه اللجنه الاقتصاديه اي مقاطعه
اخرى في نهايه المطاف يعني وانا اقولها
بصري عباره انا تحضرت ايضا الى عدد من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين الذين يتابعون هذا
المشهد قالوا طيب اذا كانت هنالك مقاطعه
نحن هنا لا نتحدث عن علاقه يعني تكافؤيه
بين الطرفين وهنالك مصالح تجاريه مشتركه
بين الطرفين من سيدفع الثمن في نهايه
المطاف هو الفلسطيني باعتبارها اسرائيل
تتعامل مع الملف الفلسطيني في بصيرين
اساسيين الاول ان هنالك مسار مالي مدني
يحاولون من خلال تهدئه اي نوع من الاحتجاج
ويعتقدون ان هذا يعني الحل سياتي بفائده
على المدى القصير على الاقل وثانيا ان
هنالك بعد امني وهذا نتابع يوميا من خلال
التوغل في المدن الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان للسلطه الفلسطينيه القدره في هذه
المرحله ان تقول على المدى البعيد لانها
لا تملك البدائل الا اذا كان واجب ان نقول
هذا اسمحيلي اذا كان هنالك نوع من شبكه
امان عربيه ودوليه يمكن ان توفر للفلسطيني
حيز مناوره حتى امام اسرائيل ولكن هذا
بحاجه الى امرين اساسيين ضغط دولي وضغط
عربي غير موجودان حتى شكرا جزيلا لكما
جاكي خوري الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه من الناصره وريتش غوتسين
مبعوث الرئيس السابق الى مفاوضات السلام
بالشرق الاوسط من شكرا
قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل ستمضي في تطوير حقل
غزه مرين للغاز قباله قطاع غزه وان ذلك
يتوقف على التنسيق الامني مع مصر والسلطه
الفلسطينيه وتشير التقديرات الى ان حقل
غزه مرين يحتوي على اكثر من تريليون قدم
مكعب من الغاز الطبيعي من جانبه اكد
اسماعيل رضوان المسؤول في حركه حماس
لرويتورز على حق الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه في كل موارده الطبيعيه
بشان حق للغاز الذي ابدت اسرائيل
استعدادها لتطويره بضمانات الامنيه سيكون
لنا حديث معمق وموسع ضمن فقره في المتابعه
بشان ابعاد هذه الخطوه وما الذي تعنيه وما
قد تحمله من تبعات
الى السودان حيث دخلت هدنه حيز التنفيذ
نائب رئيس مجلس سياده السوداني مالك عقار
قال انما ينقص الهدنه في السودان هو وضع
الاليات المناسبه اضاف عقب لقائه الرئيس
المصري في القاهره ومسؤولين اخرين ان اي
مبادره تنص على تدخل العسكري الاجنبي في
السودان غير مقبوله وان اي مبادره لحل
الازمه يجب ان تحترم سياده الدوله
السودانيه واوضح ان لقاء البرهان وحميتي
سيناقش ايقاف الحرب والوضع الانساني
والعمليه السياسيه
قضيه لقاء الفريق اول البرهان مع الفريق
في اجتماع الايجاد كانوا هنالك مجموعه من
المقترحات فهذه المجموعه من الخطرات
السودان ابدا تحفظاته لهذه المقترحات
واستعوضنا عنها بانه اللقاء الطرفين لقاء
الطرفين لمناقشه ثلاثه قضايا والاتفاق
عليها مبدئيا القضيه هو الاولى هو قضيه
ايقاف الحرب والقضيه الثانيه هي قضيه
الانسانيه العمليه الانسانيه والقضيه
الثالثه هي قضيه العمليه السياسيه
هذا وداعه الاليه ثلاثيه الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع الى الالتزام بوقف
اطلاق النار الاليه المكونه من الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد اكدت
على اهميه التزام الاطراف بالقانون
الانساني الدولي كما دعت الطرفين الى
الالتزام ايضا باعلان جده الذي وقعه
الطرفان في مايو الماضي والذي يستلزم
حمايه المدنيين وتسهيل المرور الامن
للمساعدات الانسانيه واكدت الاليه
الثلاثيه التزامها بالمساهمه في تحقيق وقف
مستقر لاطلاق النار ودعم السودانيين في
اطلاق عمليه سياسيه شامله في اقرب وقت
ممكن
في هذه الاثناء يسود هدوء حذر جبهات
القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مع
سريان الهدنه وقد حذر الوسيطان السعودي
والامريكي الطرفين من عدم الالتزام بوقف
اطلاق النار وهو ما سيضطر الوسيطين الى
النظر في تاجيل محادثات جده
لم تنطفئ النار المشتعله في السودان لكن
ثمه الثلاثه ايام اخرى من وقف اطلاق النار
يستمر اثر المعارك لكن يصود الهدوء حتى
الان بعد دخول الهدنه الجديده حيز التنفيذ
في التصريحات المتقابله يحذر الجيش من انه
سيرد على اي خرق بينما يؤكد الدعم السريع
التزامه بالوقف الكامل لاطلاق النار
تصريحان بعد تحذير الوسيطين الامريكي
والسعودي من ان عدم الالتزام سيدفع
الوسيطين الى النظر في تاجيل محادثات جده
تلك محادثات بدات في السادس من مايو اي
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من اندلاع المعارك ونجحت
في الوصول الى اعلان جده وقد تضمن حمايه
المدنيين وايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
وانسحاب القوات من المستشفيات
استمرت جده في استضافه المحادثات والوصول
الى هدى تحول بعضها الى اشباه هدى سبعه
ايام من النقف اطلاق النار في الحادي
والعشرين من مايو ثم خمسه ايام او اخر
الشهر نفسه وهكذا حتى يومنا هذا هدى هشه
متفرقه لساعات وايام قليله عاده ما كانت
تخترق باطلاق النار لكن اللافته في
الهدنتين الاخيرتين التزام الطرفين بالوقف
الكامل لاطلاق النار والهدوء ساده اثناء
هاتين الهدنتين اكثر من سابقاتهما
بالتزامن مع خشونه واضحه في لغه الوسيطين
لدفع الاطراف نحو الالتزام يبدو ان الهدنه
المتتاليه وتجديد الوسيطين اثر على
الميدان ميدانيا تتغير خريطه الاشتباكات
بشكل طفيف لكن لافت للنظر بدات المعارك
منتصف ابريل في مدينه مروش على العاصمه
وانتقلت سريعا الى الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث
كان الامر يبدو بدايه بانه سعي حثي من
الطرفين لحسم المعركه بالسيطره المباشره
على القصر الجمهوري ومقر قياده الجيش وسط
العاصمه لكن المعارك اشتعلت بشكل اكبر في
مناطق خارج العاصمه وتحديدا الابيض عاصمه
ولايه كردفان والجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب
دارفور وهنا تتقاطع البنادق وتزيد
الصراعات القبليه من قتامه المشهد وتلك
مناطق تعتبر عمقا مهما لقوات الدعم السريع
التي ترتكز فيها الاسوا من استمرار
المعارك استمرار سقوط المئات من القتلى
وفرار مئات الالاف تلك ارقام اندفعت الامم
المتحده لتنظيم مؤتمر في جنيف لتنسيق
الاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان تقول
المنظمه الامميه ان اكثر من 25 مليون
سوداني بحاجه لمساعدات لكنها اي الامم
المتحده لم تتلقى اكثر من 450 مليون دولار
من اصل مليارين و600 مليون طلبتها لمساعده
البلاد هذا العام هكذا تتلاحق المعارك
والهدن في السودان لا حسمت المعارك الامر
لصالح طرف دون اخر ولا اوقفت الهدن
المعارك بشكل نهائي
من باريس معنا محمد تورشان الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك سيد محمد اذا
هدوء حذر على الجبهات في السودان بالتزامن
مع هذه الهدنه الى ما يعود هذا الالتزام
على ما يبدو حتى الان
في البدء التحيه لك والساده المشاهدين
الكرام انا في تقديري هذا الالتزام منذ
الاذن الماضيه وحتى اليوم الاول من هذه
الهدنه التي تم اطلاقها صباح اليوم ياتي
من خلال عده عوامل اولها الضغط المستمر من
قبل الوساطه المؤثره في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لازم
بان الولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات من قبل
وزاره الخزانه على المؤسسات الجيش
السوداني وكذلك الدعم السريع فضلا عن ذلك
تقرير الخارجيه الامريكيه بالامس الغريب
تحدثوا بشكل مباشر بان الدعم السريع هو
متورط في بعض الانتهاكات في دارفور
الاجرائم ترتقي الى جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسان فضلا عن تحمي تحميله مسؤوليه
تقصير الجيش السوداني من حمايه المدنيين
العزل فضلا عن ذلك المعارك استمرت فتره
طويله على نحو شهرين وهذه فتره طويله
فينبغي الى كل طرف ان ياخذ [__] راحه ومن
بعد حتى يعيد تنظيم صفوفه وكذلك الحصول
على المؤن وعلى الامداد ومراجعه الخطط
الخطط القتاليه والعسكريه كل هذه العوامل
مجتمعه جعلت ولكن هذا الالتزام
النسبه دعنا نقول حتى الان
باعتقادك كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على المسار في
جده
وهو ايضا هنالك الجزئيه ايضا الان ملاحظ
تماما انه بالرغم من ان منبر جده طرح عدد
من المبادرات الالتزام فيها متفاوت بين
الالتزام نسبه جيد او عدم الالتزام مطلق
لكن الملاحظ حتى الان لم يطور المنبر
الاليات والادوات المنوط بها الضبط الهدن
على ارض الواقع تحديدا الجهه التي غرقت
الهدم بشكل مباشر فضلا عن ذلك محاوله
تقريبا النظر لاطلاق هدنه طويله المدى حتى
يستفيد منها المواطن بشكل كبير جدا
ومعالجه الكثير من الازمات الانسانيه
والاخفارات بحيث انه هدنه اليوم الواحد او
اليومين او الثلاث ايام لم تحقق كثير من
المعالجات للاوضاع الانسانيه بنلاحظ
الكثير من المدنيين يستغل هذه الهدنه
للخروج من دائره الاقتتال فينبغي ان تكون
هنالك هدى طويله ينبغي ان يكون هنالك تصور
لمعالجه الازمه بمعنى تصورا للدخول في
مفاوضات جاده تناقش بشكل كيفيه دمج الدعم
السريع في العسكريه يتحدث بشكل مباشر جدا
عن عمليه اجراء حوار وطني شامل بمشاركه كل
القوى السياسيه يتحدث بشكل مباشر عن تقديم
كل المتورطين والذين يرتكبوا انتهاكات
ايذاء المدني
في هذا الاطار كانت لافته ربما الاشاره
التي وردت على لسان السيد مالك عقار من ان
هناك
اشار الى لقاء بين البرهان وحماتي
بعد محادثاته في القاهره وهذه الاشاره
لافته لان الخارجيه السودانيه كانت تحفظت
على هذا البند الذي ورد في مبادره الايجاد
ماذا تعني هذه الاشاره باعتقادك على لسان
مالك عقار
انا في تقدير حتى الان المواقف السودانيه
غير متسخه بالشكل الكافي وربما يعود ذلك
لعدم انسجام المواقف نتيجه لاختلاف
المكونات السياسيه للحكومه سواء كان وزاره
الخارجيه والجيش السوداني او حتى مالك
عقار الذي اتى للمنصب خلفا لمحمد حمدان
دقله فنلاحظ ان هنالك توائم في وجهات
النظر لكن مجبره يتحدث عن في نهايه الامر
ينبغي ان تكون هنالك تسويه حتى اذا مضت
المعارك بشكل حقق انتصارات للجيش السوداني
ينبغي تعزيز هذه الله الانتصارات عن طريق
المباحثات وعن طريق جولات التفاوض لكن انا
في تقدير هذا الموقف اذا اجتمع الرجلان
ماذا سيناقشان القضيه اكبر من اجتماع محمد
حمدان دقلب البرهان بمعنى هل اذا كان
الرجلان لديهم قدره ولديهم حلول لمعالجه
هذه الازمه التي منذ فتره طويله بدات تروح
في الافق قبل الحدوث هذه المعارك لما
اعتقد انهم توصلوا الى الى هذه الارض
لقاء سيد محمد الى ان اللقاء سيناقش وقف
الحرب والوضع الانساني والعمليه السياسيه
انا اتوقع اتوقع انه انه يناقش الوقف
الحرب وهذا امر ضروري جدا ان احنا نتحدث
عن وقف الحرب بشكل جذري وهذه المعالج
النهائي باختصار
لا اتوقع في زر هذه الظروف بمعنى انه حتى
مصير محمد حمدان حتى الان غير معلوم فضلا
عن ذلك تصريحات الدعم السريع بما في ذلك
بالامس الغريب لن توافق على هذه المبادره
لانها تعود كثيرا الى مبادره المبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه بمعنى اخر هنالك فرصه
لشراء الوقت حتى تتحقق انتصارات على ارض
الواقع من بعد التفكير الجاد في المباحثه
شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى اخر تطورات هي حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه نفذت خلال اليوم الاحد
اكثر من 40 غار جويه وستين هجوما صاروخيا
على مواقع اوكرانيه ومناطق سكنيه بينما
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها صدت سلسله
هجمات كبيره اوكرانيه في ثلاثه قطاعات في
زبوروجيا ياتي ذلك بينما احتدمت المعارك
في الجبهه الجنوبيه للبلاد مما كبد
الطرفين خسائر كبيره في الارواح وفق
تقارير استخباراتيه غربيه
في اوكرانيا شريط النار قد يعبر عما يحدث
على الجبهه المشتعله الممتده على طول
المنطقه الواقعه من جنوب مقاطعه باتجاه
جنوب
مقاطعا الى مقاطعه خرسون وحديث اوكراني عن
اكثر من 40 غاره جويه روسيه وستين هجوما
صاروخيا في يوم واحد المتحدث باسم الاداره
العسكريه في اوديسا اشار الى تعرض مستودع
لذخيره في منطقه ريكوبي جنوبيه خرسون
للاستهداف ما ادى الى تفجيره بالكامل عمده
الاوكرانيه لم يتاخر عن القول ان المستودع
تستخدمه القوه الروسيه مركزا لتجميع
المعدات وتخزين الوقود وبتزامن مع قصف
متبادل في خرسون كثافه للقصف الروسي في
منطقه زابولوجيا استهدفت مواقع متقدمه بعد
انحسار مياه
وتحرك القوه الروسيه بضعه كيلومترات وفق
مراسل الجزيره المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروس قال ان القوات الروسيه صادت هجمات
لثلاث كتائب تكتيكيه اوكرانيه عند محور
زابولوجيا ودمرت مستودعه ذخيره اوكرانيا
في المقاطعه الجنوبيه منطقه تابريا مسرح
مواجهه اخرى جنوبيه
يتحدث الاوكرانيون عن تنفيذ اكثر من 1800
ضربه صاروخيه ومدفعيه خلال يوم واحد
وتدمير عشرات الاليات الروسيه لكنها تبقى
روايه من طرف واحد فالقوه الروسيه بدورها
اعلنت صد ثمن هجمات اوكرانيه عبر محور
دونيتسكو وشنت هجمات بريه على جبهه بخموت
قال نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه هجمت الضواحي الشماليه
والجنوبيه لبخموت بينما تحدث الروس عن صد
هجمات بريه اوكرانيه محدوده على خط مدينه
افديف كادونيات
مقاطعه كورسك الروسي على الحدود باتت
مهدده وفق سلطات المقاطعه التي وضعت كل
السيناريوهات لاجلاء سكان القرى والبلدات
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا بسبب وجود من وصفتهم
بمجموعه تخريب اوكرانيه على الحدود ودوما
على الحدود افاد حاكم مقاطعه
بقصف القوات الاوكرانيه لها باكثر من 120
قذيفه ومسيره تحمل عبوات ناسفه العين ايضا
على تحركات لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
الذي يعيد انتشاره بشكل مستمر في شبه
جزيره القرم وفق المتحدث باسم القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه هي تطورات لافته
التهابت معها ساحه القتال بينما اكدت
تقرير لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تكبد
الطرفي القتال خسائر كبيره في الجنود
لكنها وفق التقرير الاعلى بالنسبه للجنود
الروس منذ احتدام معركه بخموت في مارس
الماضي
من عمان ينضموا الينا اللواء فايزه دواري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
لواء فايز بياتي خاتي هو اسمه القريه التي
تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه كما تقول كما
يقول الطرف الاوكراني من استعادتها في
منطقه تازابولوجيا ما اهميه ونوعيه هذا
التقدم
يعني الان رغم التباين في التقارير من
طرفي الصراع لكن دراسه متانيه متعمقه لهذه
البيانات يستطيع ان يكون صوره اقرب الى
الواقع لا تزال الهجمات الاوكرانيه
متتاليه في اربعه مناطق من ضمنها
واقساها منطقه زبروجيا لا تزال القوات
الروسيه تخوض معارك دفاعيه اذا ملخص هذا
الموقف المبادعه التعرض تنفذه القوات
الاوكرانيه سواء في طاقموت سواء في وسط
دونيسك او فيزا بروجيا الان منطقه
زبوروجيا محور السؤال
المفتاح الرئيسي في سبولوجيا بغض النظر عن
المساويه المسميات هي مدينه توكماك
البلدات الثلاث التي
الحديث عنها والهجوم بثلاثه كتائب هو يقع
الى الشمال والشمال الغربي من توك ماك
لماذا لان الوصول الى توك ماك في تلك
اللحظه نبدا نتحدث عن انجاز عملياتي كبير
يمكن الاستفاده منه يمكن تطويره يفتح
الخيارات امام القوات الاوكرانيه لتذهب في
احد الاتجاهات الثلاث او في اكثر من فاذا
بالنظر الى الجنوب بالنظر سيد لواء فايز
بالنظر الى مسار هذا الهجوم المضاد منذ
بدايته هل يبدو هذا الانجاز الذي تتحدث
عنه ميسرا هل تستطيع القوات الاوكرانيه ان
تحققها حتى حتى حتى
هذه اللحظه الاجابه قطعا لا لكن
معظم محاولات الهجوم في منطقه جبولوجيا
تحاول الوصول الى تكمك لماذا لان توك ماك
كما قلت هي المفتاح الرئيسي
لثلاثه محاور قتال لاحقه
سواء كانت ماريوبل بيرديانسك
واي منها يقود الى ما وراعه
تقود الى عمق زجاجه الى شبه جزيره
القرمسك الى البحر
الى الميناء الرئيسي اشكرك اللواء فايزه
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا
من عمان
[موسيقى]
الى الصين وزياره هي الاولى منذ خمس سنوات
لمسؤول امريكي رفيع الخارجيه الامريكيه
قالت ان الوزير انتوني بلينكن اجرى اليوم
في بيجين محادثات صريحه وموضوعيه وبناء مع
نظيرها الصيني واشارت الى ان الوزيره
الامريكي شدد على اهميه الدبلوماسيه
والحفاظ على قنوات اتصال مع الصين للحد من
مخاطر سوء الفهم والحسابات الخاطئه واكدت
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلينكن طرح القضايا
المثيره للقلق فضلا عن فرص التعاون في
القضايا المشتركه مع الصين وافادت ان
اجتماعات بلينكن مع المسؤولين الصينيين في
بيجين ستستمر غدا الاثنين وان الوزير
الامريكي دعا نظيره صيني لزياره واشنطن
لاستكمال المناقشات
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه الصيني
ان العلاقات بين بيجين واشنطن في ادنى
مستوياتها منذ عام 1979 واكد تشين اثناء
اجتماعه مع نظيره الامريكي
مستقره وقابله للتنبؤ وبناءه مع الولايات
المتحده وابدا الوزير وزير الخارجيه
الصيني مخاوفه واضحه بشان المصالح
الرئيسيه للصين بما في ذلك قضيه تايوان
تاتي زياره الوزير الامريكي الى بيجين في
ظروف حساسه النيه وسياسيا اثرى التوتر
الذي شاب العلاقه بين القوتين العظميين
خلال الفتره الماضيه اهم نقاط التوتر
وسياق الزياره في تقرير احمد
لا حديث للصحفيين ولا افصاحه عما سيناقش
بالابتسامه خجلاء فحسب ياتي الوزير
الامريكي الى بيجين اشهرا بعد الغاء زياره
سابقه احتجاجا على ما رات هواش حينها
بالونه تجسس خيم على اراضيها ايامه على
الطاوله ملفات كثيره للنقاش فواشنطن
منزعجه من تلاميذ طموحات الصين ومن ضيقها
باي وجود غربي في غلافها الجغرافي تخشى
واشنطن كذلك من تقارب صيني روسي في ظل
التوتر في اوكرانيا
فقد كثفت الصين تدريباتها العسكريه خلال
شرب الماضيه وابرزت عضلاتها مرارا لافهم
واشنطن ان ايام الاذلال الغربي لها قد ولد
حسب الدارس في تصريحات المسؤولين الصينيين
مشاغل الصين كثيره فهي تشعر بان واشنطن
تسعى لتطويقها امنيا وسياسيا فهي تحيطها
بتحالفات عسكريه قصد احكام الخناق حول
العملاق الاسيوي المتوسب للاقلاع فهناك
تحالف اوكوس الذي يضم استراليا والمملكه
المتحده والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقد
اقيم عام 2021 ضمن توجه من اداره بايدن
لجعل اسيا منطقه محوريه استراتيجيا اما
واشنطن فترى اوكوس تحالفا عزيزي التعاون
وضبط الامن في المحيط الهادي انشات
الولايه المتحده كذلك تحالف اكواد المؤلفه
منها ومن اليابان والهند واستراليا وهو
تكتل عسكري قائم منذ العام 2007 لكن بايدن
قام باحيائه عندما تسلم السلطه واجتمع
بقادته اواخر عام 2021 في واشنطن مما رفع
قرون الاستشعار في بيجين من الاشكاليات
بين القوتين العظميين كذلك قلق الصين من
اتساع اجنده الناتو ومواقفه بشان تايوان
وعلاقاته بغلافها الاستراتيجي فالمحيط
القريب من الصين ذو علاقه وثيقه بواشنطن
فهناك دول اسيويه كاليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه تمثل مصدر قلق لبيجين بسبب
انسجامها مع خطط الناتو خاصه مع وجود
نزاعات حدوديه بحريه لها مع بعض تلك الدول
ياتي هذا وسط اتهامات متباد له بالتجسس لا
تكاد تتوقف مع حصار تقني تفرضه واشنطن على
بيجين خاصه فيما يتعلق بالرقائق
الالكترونيه كل هذا يجعل العلاقات بين
بيجين واشنطن حساسه
دومالصراع العمالقه اجواءه وادواته وان
كثرت الزيارات واتسعت الابتسامات
من بيجين ينضموا الينا فيكتور جاو نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه ومن نيويورك
معنا دانس مدير مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق لشؤون الصين مرحبا بكما
سيد دانس وايلدر ما المامول من هذه
المحادثات بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده كانت
متشوقه لان تجري هذه الزياره للوزير
بلينكن التي لم يقم بها في السنه بدايه
قبل فتره وذلك لتعزيز العلاقات ولابقائها
من التدهور والمزيد من التدهور وايضا
لمناقشه بعض الخلافات الاراء الواضحه
وايضا بعض المجالات التي يمكن ايجاد تعاون
بين الصين ولايه المتحده فيها كما
كما قال الرئيس بايدن من الولايات المتحده
لا تريد ان تكون في نزاع او خلاف مع الصين
تجد مجالات التعاون معها في اثناء تنافسنا
معها فيكتور جاو على ماذا يعول الجانب
الصيني ايضا من هذه المحادثات
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه اولا الان وقد قام
الوزير لينك ان في بزيارته وبدا باول يوم
وحداتي في بيجين وخلال بضعه الساعات
سيستيقظ ويبدا بيومه الثاني من نقاشات
وهذا امر مهم جدا قد يتعلق الامر
بالعلاقات بين البلدين ولكن من جانب اخر
الوزير بلانكن هو الذي قرر الغاء
رحلته او زيارته في بدايه فبراير وتحمل
نتائج قراراته الاجتماع الهام الذي يجري
حاليا تاخر باكثر من اربعه اشهر
اربعه اشهر ونصف وهذا ليس جيد بالنسبه
للعلاقات بين البلدين من وجهه نظر الصين
اعتقد الصين اريد ان تتاكد هل يريدون
التعامل مع الصين كبلد يمكن التوافق معه
رغم الخلافات بينهما او ان الولايات
المتحده تريد التعامل مع الصين كال دوله
عدوه فكره الحالتين الصين مستعده ان تقوم
بالعمل الصحيح والصاعد
اعتقد ان السيد دانس جاوب مسبقا على هذا
على هذا النقطه بقوله ان الرئيس بايدن ذكر
ان امريكا لا تريد النزاع مع الصين في
اطار التنافس معها
في الواقع الضروره هي
الاصغاء الى الكلام
ومجاهده العمل لا اعتقد تصير بالطريقه
الصحيحه او تتحدث في الكلام المناسب ينبغي
ان ننظر خير من خلال كل هذه
الاقنعه وتحاول تقولها الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده قلقه بان الصين ستتفوق
على الاقتصاد الامريكي وانه لا تنتهي
تعاني من كوابيس بان الصين قد تفرض نظامها
السياسيه حتى خارج الولايات المتحده وهذا
امر خاطئ تماما الصيص يتعامل مع الولايات
المتحده كما هي مع جميع دول العالم
كند وليت لا تحاول ان تفرض ارائه عن
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي هذا يعني في
هنا الطرفين يجب ان يتفقها ان الحرب لا
تكون خيارا بين البلدين لكن الصين لن تخرج
لتفرض
نظامها السياسي عن الولايات المتحده هذا
هو جوهر الموضوع الولايات المتحده عليها
ان تفهم بان تصير بلد كبير ومهم جدا
ويتوسع وسيكون اكبر من الولايات المتحده
في نهايه المطاف وايضا مرتاح
على هذه النقطه
ان السيد قال ما يقوله يثبت فقدان الثقه
المتبادل الذي ينبغي ان نعمل عليه في هذه
العلاقه الولايات المتحده ترى هي عدائيه
في بحر جنوب الصين وترى ان الصين تكون
بنشاطين عسكريه مضر ضد التايوان
وبناء بحريه قويه جدا وقوه استراتيجيه
وهناك شعور لدى جانب الامريكي هو انماطير
الصين حقيقه هو ان اللايت متحده ان تبتعد
عن منطقه المحيط الهادي وشرق
البحر الصين رئيس الصيني انه يخشى ان
الولايات المتحده تحاول احتاء وقمعه الصين
وبالتالي ما لدينا هنا هو
عدم ثقه متبادل وكبير والطريق الوحيد لحل
ذلك هو عن الدبلوماسيه
لاعاده زيارات وتبادلات
شكرا
اشكركما مدير مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق لشؤون الصين ضيفنا من نيويورك
وفيكتور جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه من بيجين
صدر في الكويت مرسوم امري بتشكيل الحكومه
الجديده برئاسه الشيخ احمد نواف الاحمد
الجابر الصباح وشهدت الحكومه وعوده الشيخ
احمد الفهد نائبا لرئيس الوزراء ووزيرا
للدفاع وتعيين اربعه نواب رئيس الوزراء
واحتفاظ كلا من وزير الخارجيه الشيخ سالم
عبد الله الجابر الصباح ووزير الداخليه
الشيخ طلال خالد الاحمد الصباح بمنصبيهما
من الكويت معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره سعد
السعيدي سعد ما الذي يلفظ في هذه التشكيله
وكما يقال هنا في الكويت واخيرا خرجت هذه
الحكومه وان كان هذا الخروج متعسرا كما
يبدو بسبب محاوله اقناع عضو من اعضاء مجلس
الامه الخمسين للدخول في التشكيل الحكوميه
وهذا اجراء دستوري يجب ان يتضمن التشكيل
الحكوميه على الاقل واحد من اعضاء مجلس
الامه وبالتالي يعني خرجت في الساعات
الاخيره وفقا للماده 87 من الدستور يجب ان
يكون او ان تاتي دعوه البرلمان للانعقاد
بعد اسبوعين من انتهاء الانتخابات
وبالتالي يصادف هذا يوم الثلاثاء بعد غد
دعوه او افتتاح دور الانعقاد وبالتالي يجب
ان تكون هناك حكومه جاهزه وحكومه جديده في
غضون 14 يوم يجب ان تكون هذه الحكومه
جاهزه هذه الحكومه هي الخامسه للشيخ احمد
النواب في غضون حقه عام تقريبا ابرز اعضاء
هذه الحكومه او ابرز ما في هذه الحكومه
انها جاءت بسته اعضاء جدد ابرز هؤلاء
الاعضاء الجدد وهو حاجه يملك شعبيه هنا
الشيخ احمد الفهد الصباح وهو شخصيه رياضيه
عالميه ومعروفه حقيقه حتى على المستوى
العالمي معروف هنا في الكويت بشكل كبير
جدا تقلد مناصب كثيره منذ العام 2001 ايضا
كان رئيس المجلس الاولمبي الاسيوي تراس
ايضا منظمه اوبك في الاعوام الماضيه قبل
ان يخرج من المشهد منذ عام 2015 ويعود
اليوم يعود وهذه العوده قد تكون تخلق
تعاونا بين السلطتين او هو لاعب مهم حقيقه
كل المختلفين او المتفقين مع الشيخ احمد
الفهد الا انه لاعب مهم سيكون في التوليف
الحكوميه القادمه ومحاوله دفع الحكومه
والبرلمان الى محاوله تعاون بين السلطتين
بعد ان حقيقه يعني مل الجميع من هذه
الامور التي تجري في الكويت دائما ما بين
احل وابطار ثم انتخابات ثم تشكيله جديده
حكومه جديده وبالتالي هذا خلق يعني عدم
استقرار في البلاد لذلك
يؤمل ان تؤدي هذه التوليفه الحكوميه وهي
خرجت مكتمله هذه الحكومه خمسه عشر وزيرا
بخلاف رئيس الوزراء يوم ان تؤدي يعني اداء
جيدا مع وتسير بتعاون مع البرلمان في
المرحله اللاحقه شكرا لك مدير المكتب
الجزيره في الكويت سعد السعيد
اوقفت السلطات اليونانيه عمليات البحث عن
ناجين ومفقودين في حادث غرق قارب كان يقل
اكثر من 700 من طالبي اللجوء في هذه
الاثناء بعض اقارب الضحايا خفر السواحل
اليوناني بتعمد اغراق السفينه وتواصل
محكمه يونانيه تحقيقات في الملابسات
مكتفيه حتى الان بتوجيه التهمه الى تسعه
ناجين مصريين تقول انهم ينتمون الى شبكه
اجراميه لتهريب البشر
الشرطه اليونانيه وهي تنقل بعض الناجين من
حادث غرق سفينه اللاجئين على شهادتهم
تعاون السلطات للكشف عن ملابسات الفاجعه
لكنها لا تسمح لهم بالحديث الى اي كان غير
ان بهاء خليفه الذي جاء الى كلماته للبحث
عن ابن عمه المفقود تمكن من استقاء شهادات
من جينا تكشف عن تفاصيل الدقائق الاخيره
لللحظات الاخيره هم كانوا من اربعه ايام
موجودين مياه البحر وضائعين
السلطات اليونانيه معها خبر السلطات
الايطاليه معها خبر عده دول معها خبر
بوجود ضياع القارب والقارب معروف وين هو
وباي اتجاه رايه ووين ضاع ما حداش بادر
مساعده القارب ولما بادروا بمساعده القارب
عن اقوال احد الناجين هم اللي غرقوهم
جروهم بحبل وبسرعه عاليه
ترفض السلطات اليونانيه هذه الاتهامات
جمله وتفصيلا وخفر سواحل اكد في بيان رسمي
انه عرض مرارا عبر الراديو ومكبرات الصوت
مساعده السفينه يوم الاربعاء اثناء
ابحارها في المياه الدوليه متجهه من ليبيا
الى ايطاليا لكن ركابها رفضوا المساعده
واكد ان اي جهد لسحب سفينه الصيد المقتظه
او نقل مئات الاشخاص غير الراغبين في ذلك
الى السفن القريبه كان سيمثل خطرا كبيرا
للغايه
والى ان يحدد القضاء اليوناني المسؤول
المباشر عن هذا الحادث كشف بعض اهالي
الضحايا عن تفاصيل هذه الرحله التي كلفتهم
4000 وخمسمائه دولار مبلغ يشمل الانتقال
من سوريا الى مطار بنغازي ثم الى بلده
قنبوت بالشرق الليبي حيث انطلقت السفينه
المنكوبه التي توقف محركها بعد ثلاثه ايام
من الابحار ليتم اصلاحه بعد ذلك الى ان
وقعت الفاجعه بعد انتهاء عمليات البحث عن
المفقودين تستمر تحقيقات السلطات
اليونانيه التي تتهم الان تسعه من الناجين
بتنظيم رحله اسفرت عن غرق سفينه كانت تقل
المئات تحقيقات يامل اهالي الضحايا ان
تكشف عن ملابسات الكارثه واسباب عجز خفر
السواحل اليونانيه عن انقاذ ذويهم اي
منازوبير الجزيره من مدينه كلماتا
بالعوده الى خبر حقل الغاز في المياه
الاقليميه الفلسطينيه الذي ابدت اسرائيل
استعدادها لتطويره بضمانات امنيه من
السلطه الوطنيه ومصر يوجد حقل غزه مرين
للغاز الطبيعي على مسافه نحو 36 كيلومترا
قباله ساحر قطاع غزه ويقع الحق الحق الذي
اكتشف اواخر التسعينات على عمق اكثر من
600 متر تحت سطح البحر المتوسط اما
احتياطي الحقل فيقدر بحوالي 32 مليار متر
مكعب اي ما يعادل طاقه انتاج سنويه تبلغ
مليارا ونصف مليار متر مكعب لمده 20 عاما
وهذا الاحتياطي الضخم يفوق بكثير احتياجات
الاراضي الفلسطينيه من طاقه ويمكن تصدير
كميات كبيره منه وفقا لقانون البحار اكدت
اتفاقيات اوسلو ان حقله غزه مارين يقع تحت
ولايه السلطه الفلسطينيه الا ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يمنع الفلسطينيين من الوصول
الى مواردهم البحريه حقل غزه مرين كان منذ
سنوات موضع
رهان السلطه الفلسطينيه حيث سعت الى
تطويره ليكون رافعه اقتصاديه وماليه
ومصدرا لطاقه الكهربائيه للاراضي
الفلسطينيه ففي ابريل عام 2018 توصل صندوق
الاستثمار الفلسطيني الى اتفاق مع شركه
النفط الاوروبيه شل بشان خروجها من رخصه
تطوير حقل غزه مرين واستبدالها بتحالف
جديد يتكون من صندوق الاستثمار وشركه
اتحاد المقاولين الفلسطينيه
نص التفاهم على ان تكون حصه التحالف
الجديد 55% مناصفه بين الطرفين على ان يتم
تخصيص 45% لشركه عالميه مطوره يتم
اختيارها والتصديق عليها لاحقا وفي فبراير
من عام 2021 ابرم صندوق الاستثمار
الفلسطيني اتفاقا مع شركتي اتحاد
المقاولين وشركه المصريه القابضه للغازات
الطبيعيه ايجاز لتطوير الحقل وتوفير
احتياجات الفلسطينيين من الغاز الطبيعي
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام الله
محمود نواجعه المنسق العام لحمله مقاطعه
اسرائيل مرحبا بك سيد محمود عمليا ماذا
يعني القرار الذي اعلن عنه اليوم نتنياهو
مساء الخير اهلا وسهلا بكم هو قرار مبدئي
بصراحه باعطاء امكانيه استخراج الغاز
الفلسطيني من حق من حق الغزه وهذا يعني
ياتي من خلال شركه ايجي غاز المصريه والتي
كما اسلفتم تمتلك 45% من الحصه هذا هذا
الحقل ولكن هذا ايضا مرهون بضمانات امنيه
ومرهون بالتنازلات اخرى نعتقد من السلطه
الفلسطينيه وربما ربما صمتها على سرقه
اسرائيل لحقول الغاز الفلسطيني الاخرى في
المنطقه الفلسطينيه الاقتصاديه الخالصه
والتي تتجاوز خمسه تريليون قدم مكعب
وبالتالي هي اكثر بكثير من حق الغزه او
بما يقارب الخمس الخمس اضعاف وهذا يعني
كمان تسوق مع خطط الاحتلال التي كانت قد
فرضت خارطه بحريه مشوهه هي فقط فيها حقل
غزه المذكور وتشبه المثلث اولا
يقول الو
زراء لتعد لتطوير حقل الغاز هذا بضمانات
امنيه من السلطه الفلسطينيه ومصر عمليا
ماذا يعني من الذي سيطور هذا الحقل ولمن
ستعود العائدات
هو كل موضوع الغاز يلفه الغموض بصراحه لان
السلطه الفلسطينيه لا لا تنشر معلومات
صادقه حتى حتى اتفاقيه
منتدى غاز شرق المتوسط لم لم تقم بنشر
بنود التي اكتشفنا لاحقا انها بنود تقنيه
وليست حقوق سياسيه ولا تشمل حدود الحدود
البحريه ايضا هي الضمانات الامنيه المقصود
بها الضغط على مصر باتجاه اي ضمان امني
وان تكون مصر هي التي تتحمل مسؤوليه
الخط الغاز على سبيل على سبيل المثال لا
سيما ان خط الغاز الذي ياتي من الاحتلال
يذهب الى مصر هو قريب جدا من شواطئ من
شواطئ غزه وبالتالي امنيا هو لا تعود على
الحقل غزه ولكن هي تعود على تامين سرقه
اسرائيل لمواردنا الطبيعيه بالذات مرور
هذه الموارد من خلال الحقل الذي يمر بجانب
قطاع غزه الى مصر الى العريش وايضا تامين
سرقتها للموارد الاضخم والاكبر في البحر
المتوسط والتي تتجاوز خمسه ريال قدم مكعب
والتي اعلن الاحتلال عن اكتشافها سابقا
وهم حقلان اسمائهم الشمس
وروي بالاضافه الى تجفيفه حقول سابقا كانت
في المنطقه البحريه الفلسطينيه ايضا او
على اقل تقدير المنطقه المشتركه وبالتالي
ما يحدث اليوم للاسف الشديد نعتقد انه
شراء لصمت السلطه الفلسطينيه على نهب
الاحتلال لمواردنا الطبيعيه الاكبر
والاضخم من اجل تامينها ماليا لعده سنوات
قادمه ايضا في التوقيت يعني اليس لافتا ان
يتم هذا الاعلان من جانب نتنياهو يوم
اعلان اختصار اجراءات البناء الاستيطاني
في الضفه
بالتاكيد هذه هي المعادله هي هو فعليا لم
يعطينا شيء جديد هذا الحقل يجب ان كان يجب
استخراج الغاز منه منذ فتره منذ فتره
طويله ولكن ما يقوم به نتنياهو سياسه
العصا والجزره هو الان يشرعني الاستيطان
ويبني وحدات استطينيه من خلال
امنيه ولا عسكريه ولا حتى موافقه رئيس
الوزراء وبالتالي ضوء اخضر لابتلاع كافه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه من خلال بناء بناء
مستوطنات ومصادره الاراضي واستكمال خطط
تطهير العرق الممنهج للشعبنا الفلسطيني
وهذا كله من اجل استدامه السلطه السلطه
ماليا في حين انه يقوم ايضا باقتطاع اموال
ضخمه جدا تستطيع استدام السلطه ماليا من
خلال فقط استرجاع هذه الاموال وبالتالي
للاسف الشديد السلطه الفلسطينيه ترتضي هذا
الاختطاع وترتضي كل ما يحدث وتذهب باتجاه
تطوير حق الغزه الذي يلفه ايضا الغموض على
سبيل المثال يجب ان تكون سلطه الطاقه بعقد
كل هذه الاتفاقيات بينما يقوم بها الدكتور
محمد مصطفى كمستشار لرئيس
للسيد لرئيس سلطه الفلسطينيه وهو في نفس
الوقت رئيس صندوق الاستثمار وبالتالي على
الاقل تقدير كما جاء في تقرير مؤسسه امان
هناك تضارب للمصالح وهو هناك شبهات كبيره
يعني فساد تلف هذا الملف بشكل كبير المنسق
والعام لحمله مقاطعه اسرائيل من رام الله
بهذا مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
حصادي هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم ننتقل
الان الى جوله منتصف الليل يرافقكم فيها
زين العابدين توفيق وواسيل علمي